there's a streamer his name's atriarch I
saw this yeah yeah it was blown up
everywhere basically uh yeah atriak is
his name basically he and Dick to
fake versions of
twitch streamers Yeah so basically he's
on he's on stream and then basically
they see like a PornHub thing like a
link on his desktop yeah and one of the
tabs is for a website that's deep fake
deep fake about another popular female
streamer I think a few other popular
female streamers but he doesn't have to
okay go on and if anyone doesn't know
deep faking is basically when you are
able to use AI to take someone's face
and then put it on a an existing porn
video so the porn video looks like to do
anything yeah people deep fake yeah
Morgan Freeman talking they Deepak
comedians on other people's bodies this
happens that's a good clarification so
deep fake porn is doing the same exact
thing but putting someone's face onto so
you could book Kamala Harris on uh
what's the girl's name Tiffany Trump or
whatever her name is Tiana Tiana Trump
yeah and then all of a sudden it looks
like Kamala Harris is the greatest
giving head ever yeah right which is
probably razor approval rating honestly
yeah it might might she might need it
great idea deep fake it honestly yeah
yeah
real talk but yeah so obviously that
brings up like deep foreign brings a
bunch of ethical issues in general of
course and this guy's situation was
weird because he's in the streaming
community and he's like this is like
more inside ship people aren't exactly
sure about this part but basically he's
good friends with another streamer this
guy Ludwig and Ludwig is dating this
girl who's another very popular
attractive streamer hey yo we're like
that's what I'm saying and so people are
like okay that's weird and then on top
of that he knows some of these other
streamers tangentially like Pokemon and
other people that were confirmed on his
desktop so people are like why did he
just say yo somebody sent it to me I
opened it I was like nah this is crazy
because if somebody was like yo they
deep faked Pokeman into this porno
Pokemon is above 18 right yeah I believe
so okay so well let's see the other one
I believe so is that in jail I believe
so everybody believes so 26 years
I believe so let me keep talking well I
believe she is I don't want to confirm
it without knowing that all right what
did you just say she's like looking
mature now
[Music]
this is part of his apology I don't ever
close tabs maybe the most nightmarish
apology of all time we should not have
what do you think is better what I just
suggested our costume what we're about
to watch the lake create a pattern of
behavior where I really want especially
women
safer like I uh we call [__] buba
spam cringe we don't do that there I've
never made like a [__] weird I don't
know sea sniffing drill I've never done
anything like that I've never done
anything crying behind his wife oh my
God tolerating he takes behavior in the
chat oh we banned it on site
and uh and like I've done this
consistently over and over and over and
then [__] at 2am
you know I've been watching so much
[__] I've been reading so much
[__] AI stuff I'm reading all this
[__] stuff about Ai and and uh and
[__] defect music and everything and
I'm in these [__] discords and I was
still so embarrassing to me but I was on
[__] PornHub dude I was on a [__]
regular ass normal [__] website and
there was an ad there's an ad on every
[__] video for this [__] so I know
other people must be clicking it because
it's on every [__] video for [__]
teeth and basically says then I clicked
it and I just I was just exploring it
and I'm never gonna do this again this
wife gets on and she's like look I don't
think he's gonna do it again and it's
just like a PR nightmare like let me get
this straight here he clicked on some
[__] that anybody would click on and
he's crying apologizing now people are I
think that they are able to deduce that
he signed up for it oh [__] me again
this is kind of speculative still
because this just happened so if you
were like oh you signed up for it in
order to upload images what does that
mean so like you have to actually made
it that's yeah uh he made himself he's
like how do I make this girl in the porn
look like what's the whole story that's
the thing it's all expected
speculation because this all they know
is what he said and what they saw in his
like his tabs yeah but they just saw the
name in the tab so how do how do they
even know what the point I actually
don't know exactly what this are because
all the pictures I've seen are blurred
so it's the twitch thing but then the
actual image of what they saw is blur it
out so I can't even see exactly oh he
had the tabs open like you can I think
so yeah oh he's an idiot so that's the
other thing it's like you don't have
this [__] super expensive setup where
you work and then you're also beating
dick on there like don't do that I mean
you could be yeah I have a porn computer
man no because I saw that money to have
like the perfect sound that's your word
that's where you do work so people don't
work
big while he's editing some [__] yeah
remember you saw the KY in the [__]
bed yeah you remember that yeah remember
that okay that's why it's [__] so
loose right now
that's crazy
listen listen this is so peculiar why is
he crying
I mean it's just weird his whole career
is over yeah that's how he feels he
feels he careers over because the whole
Community is coming at it but what's
wrong deep fake porn of his homies girl
that's where it's crazy or even just
acquaintances at the very least
acquaintances but his homies girls
famous bruh it's also it's also all
these girls famous that's also not watch
out if one of y'all start dating watch
out don't do that no I like it do it
it's kind of fun okay if if Doug starts
dating Kim Kardashian I can't look her
feet no more when she posts you you
can't go out here
new feet picks old feet picks the same
feet I think once he starts day now you
can't look no more no no no I'm not
gonna say I do it publicly
but that's what he's doing privately he
got he he got caught by itself say sorry
to your man's big yo my bad but like I
was beating dick to your girl before
like I'm grandfathered in if we're gonna
do Devil's Advocate it's not actually
his girl
oh he's shut up his girl's face and
that's it
off to the face come on bro you're not
beating up to the face
I'm not beating off versus five percent
of you this is not gonna hold up
right now public opinion it's not gonna
hold up it's the whole face on some
woman's body that's getting smashed
another woman but now imagine a girl way
more of it is not your girl than is your
now make it slightly more personal just
imagine if you could do it
and other people are not you that's why
people how the world's works that's my
point oh hold on let me think about it
hold on let me talk about other people
not
beat up
sir no no I don't know if I want this
but it does but then you make it one
percent more personal and you go huh
don't make it any percentage somebody
did it to your moms like if they they
made it they took her body and put
someone else's face on it that would be
[__] why you can't just beat off to
my mom yo still got a good enough body
as is
[Music]
[Laughter]
if he signed up for it put her face in
it that's crazy
if you put her face that's [__] right
and he signed up too because that's
investment if he was sent a link like yo
look at this deep fake a blah blah click
it real quick like this is gonna be
funny oh [__] it's man real and then
done of course that's different that's
different but you have mad tabs open up
he's crying about it on the internet so
it seems like his intent was different
yeah but he's a [__] idiot why would
you cry on the internet you could just
pretend it's something else okay so
clearly it's not something else because
that's why he's crazy he must have been
found out in a way that's like I can't
this man is foolish bro yeah so his
action you're giving him the Shaggy
defense basically it wasn't me it was in
the face of all logic it was it wasn't
me so he shouldn't have done this all
right we can all agree he shouldn't have
done it but then it brings up a bigger
question about deep fake porn that's
where it gets crazy that's illegal let's
talk about that we're trying to make it
outright illegal for two reasons one
obviously it's weird when you put
someone's face that's not on a porn
video into a porn video that's that
feels weird and then on top of that
there's porn stars that are like what
the [__] like you're going on my only
fans that's graffiti I'm supposed to be
getting parts of graffiti but also only
fans girls are like hey you're supposed
to pay me for my content but now I'm
putting my [__] out there for free are
you putting my face on someone else's
thing and now I'm not getting paid for
it oh I was thinking the other one yeah
yeah yeah yeah so now people are like
yeah it should be illegal this this
should should be completely using my
likeness to gain money on a sexual level
using the fake should be illegal in
general yeah I agree like just the
technology should be illegal Don't make
me say anything I say yeah don't make
anybody say anything to say it's a cool
thing to look at you're like wow that's
crazy we can actually do that right now
but it's terrifying it should be illegal
to use if it's not you what if you
license it out well well I think there
is a scenario where you can use it as
you Vin Diesel's does this with movies
yeah so he's licensing up basically he
has like Aphasia where he can't really
act that well anymore because like his
face he has like a disability and so
what they did is they like that's the
same [__] Bruce Willis I think Bruce
Willis I'm sorry yeah yeah it's so hard
to get them yeah yeah yeah you know what
I mean so anyway Dana White has this
thing where
no Bruce Willis has Aphasia and so as a
result he can't be in his movies anymore
so his estate has like a license for his
face and they're able to visually put
his face into movies using this
technology oh wow and it makes sense I
didn't know that was happening yeah it
also it also I saw some [__] that
[__] I want us to use but like
basically what you can do is you can
you know how we read the ads right there
on that screen right there and I heard
about this so you can basically uh fix
your eyes in post using this thing so it
makes it look like your eyes are still
looking into the camera even though
you're reading off screen in that you're
a girl can tell you a story but you're
actually on your phone bang that's a
good one for real life but we need to
find a way to do that yeah
you're right yeah once everyone gets
sunglasses where everything's augmented
reality then yeah exactly you can't
trust it but that's what they were doing
in Hollywood like it costs a lot to
capture people but basically they're
creating your digital human so like
what's happening Bruce Willis or like it
for you insurance so in case you know
what happened to Paul Walker there were
reshoots or even the positive version of
that is like you doing a brand deal in
let's stick with the Positive version
yeah
I'll start the positive
it's not gonna work but isn't that
didn't they do something I'll do it if
you want to do it
[Music]
Leonardo DiCaprio could act forever into
eternity that's the idea yeah yeah
that's gonna suck we go that sucks for
new actors yeah I know you're [__]
wait what do you mean that's how new
stars used to rise up as the All-Stars
aged out Robert Redford aged out of
whatever the [__] so Brad Pitt could
take people are gonna age out of taste
too if you want to see Marlon Brando act
yeah I understand what he's saying it's
gonna it's gonna elongate people's
careers a little bit of course they did
that [__] with uh what was that Scorsese
movie on Netflix
that was fire it looked good too it did
it did yeah but now in China I think
they're passing legislation that says if
it's a deep fake it has to be on
whatever
no yeah if you were doing something
racism and I feel like that was I'm glad
you stopped yourself this is growth
actually I did grow this is gross I'm
looking out for miles miles got to edit
the Pod yeah you know so I'm not gonna
make that joke respect thank you for now
I'm not gonna make that deep fake joke
water getting cloudy yeah Welcome to New
York